الله سبحانه
وتعالى
قران الله سبحانه
وتال
[Silence]
‏do
سهه
محرم ذ القعده ذو
الحجه
المحرم
رجب
[Silence]
محرم
ابو هريره رضي الله
عن صلى الله عليه
وسلم رمضان
محرم
عاشرا الله سبحانه
وتعالى سيدنا موسى عليه
السلام ابن عباس رضي الله تعالى عنهما
[Silence]
ابن ع ضالى
عنهما صلى الله عليه
وسلم
محرم
محرم الله سبحانه
وتعالى
موى
موسى عليه
السلام الله سبحانه
وتعالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم عليه
السلام
صلى الله عليه
وسلم ابن عباس رضي الله
عنهما صلى الله عليه
وسلم مح
محرم
عاشوراء الامام مسلم رحمه
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
[Silence]
مج
سيدنا سيدنا عمر خليفه رضي الله عنه ابو
موسى الاشعري رضي الله عنه سيدنا عم رضي
الله
عنه سيدنا عمر رضي الله
عنهه
ask صحابه رضي الله
عنهم صلى الله عليه
وسلم
هجره
should صلى الله عليه
وسلم سيدنا عمر رضي الله عنه الله
الله سبحانه
[Silence]
وتالى
سيدنا عمر رضي الله
عنه ربع
الاول
رمضان عثمان بن
عفان علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله تعالى عنهم
اجمعين
محرم ذو
الحجه
عليه
وسلم
محاكم الله
خي
[Silence]
الله
مد
‏we need to
be and
nation
na الله سبحانه وتالى in all affs so that
we ach
[Silence]
‏open
‏man الله سبحانه وتالى الله سبحانه
وتال in
all
[Silence]
اسلام
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحه
[Silence]
وتال
صلى الله عليه وسلم الامام
الحسين
‏that the make and exp what happen
on next fr ان شاء
الله
over place كبلا ان شاء الله
تعالى
الله م اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين واعلي كلمتي الحق والدين اللهم
من اراد بالمسلمين سوء فاجعل دائره السوء
تدور عليه اللهم اغفر لنا وارحمنا وتب
علينا
وسامحنا يا ربنا بالصالحات اعمالنا اللهم
واغفر للجماعه الحاضرين ووالدينا ووالديهم
الذين شهدوا لك بالوحدانيه ولنبيك
بالرساله وماتوا على ذلك اللهم انا نعوذ
بك من الهم والحزن ونعوذ بك من العجز
والكسل ونعوذ بك من البخل والجبن والمرض
والهرم ونعوذ بك من غلبه الدين وقهر
الرجال اللهم فرج هم المهمومين ونف كرب
المكروبين اللهم وفك اسر الماسورين وسجن
المسجونين اللهم عليك
بالظالمين اللهم اضرب الظالمين
بالظالمين واخرج المسلمين من بين ايديهم
سالمين اللهم احقن دماء المسلمين في كل
مكان اللهم احقن دماء المسلمين في العراق
وسوريا والصومال وباكستان ومين يمار
وافغانستان وفي كل مكان يا رب العالمين
اللهم ولهم خيارهم ولا تولهم اشرار ولا
تحاسبهم على ما فعل السفهاء منهم اللهم
ايدنا بنصرك المبين يا عزيز ويا غفار ويا
ستار ويا الله واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله
رب العالمين ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان
وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء
والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون واقم الصلاه يرحمك الله